what up with a gla double doll sign shot
that's right glasses Malone and you can
check me out on my homeboy the bootle
cev podcast kicking these facts man cuz
Kev tripping everything ain't a classic
Kev he's a
liar all right guys glasses Malone is on
the show we have uh his new album cancel
these
nuts cancel these nuts yeah yeah it's
here y got the hard copies old school yo
I haven't seen a real like dope CD in a
while it's really dope too like man we
did a team we really put that together
and it's nice came out so
nice oh yeah it's really nice this is a
real CD yeah yeah replicated and people
can go online and get the autograph
version the [__]
store.com I like that now let me ask you
something when you do something called
the [__] store.com are there other Crips
that feel some type of way that they're
cuz you know there's there's um so many
Crips there's [__] Cola sure there was
the CRI shout out to Mike there was the
Crips that claimed like [__] LLC that
tried to sue nip yeah that was funny um
so you have the Crips store does anyone
own the Crips uh I don't know on the
business side I don't know I wouldn't
even really worry about it I wouldn't
even think twice about it it seems like
a non-p thing to do the [__] store no no
no I'm saying like a non-p thing to do
to be like I trademarked that it's
definitely a non-p thing to do I don't
know any Crips actively looking
to copyright that term to Crips I just
would say that's just a bit broad you
know I I think most cribs look at it
like it's just a broad concept we all
being right in the eye of the storm we
all understand cripping is a much more
diverse thing and everybody has their
own claim to it as far as Los Angeles
goes and now across the world um I
listen to the album my favorite is the
uh 21 stemi flow that's tight I like
uh us with d smoke that was dope one of
the guy La Giants had uh La Giants are
on that record right y yeah it was both
of Jo the first verse that they did was
super dope when they were like Kendall
Jenner wouldn't have her lips oh yeah
yeah that's Joey Joey West he killed
that [__] like yeah yeah you're right
yeah and he went right before Cam and
you know that's Cam's that's right
within uh West Coast Cam's wheelhouse my
OG West bro yeah that's his wheelhouse
so for Joey to go he he got off
yeah no he did his thing man album is
dope um it's kind of like a it feels
like a little like obviously it's your
album but you you obviously have the LA
Giants heavily intertwined throughout
the project yeah they just fit what was
going on at the time are they like blue
division no no they got they got their
own label giant life okay I just Market
their stuff okay so I mean I guess they
are blue division to some degree but
really it was about helping them build
their own thing yeah you take a liking
to them and wanted to
help um I I've been knowing them
probably 20 years you know what I mean
I've always liked them but I just think
uh God created a space I forgive me for
getting all extra spiritual but he
created a space and I realized we had so
many things in common this late in our
life and so [__] we just start working
and they was talking about jumping on
records and I just long as they had fun
and they end up being like way better
you know what I mean than I ever could
have thought like I would have never
thought walking into it we was going to
be making this many records right are we
rolling yeah okay we're talking M cut C
cord cut out we're talking about the LA
Giants obviously they're all over the
project yeah um they just fit they just
fit we the same type of what's crazy is
because all of these artists I've worked
with um I can't say everybody had as
much of a la experience as I have right
everybody hasn't been a gang banger if
they have they haven't low they haven't
had a low rider been on CR y um if they
have you know maybe they never sold dop
or if they have maybe they never street
race you maybe they never functioned the
LA johs was like the first acts that I
worked with to me that did all of the
same La things that I
did including risk your life for some
good chicken yes yeah yeah it's [__]
true which is a which is song number
seven yeah Jim Dandy but it's like that
in so many different places it's funny
because that's like a TV show I'm
finishing up I wrode and I'm F to shoot
uh van Le a couple homies helping me to
produce it but um dying at your own
wrist that's the experience in La yeah
there are always people who are like yo
man there's some great cuz what's the
the OG Louisiana chicken is where and
they tray and it's like if if you're
over there danger it's dangerous but
that's how it is uh so Jim dandies and
Denver Lange Bloods right then you have
Hawkins and across street from the
Nickerson Gardens the Bonnie oners um
Lou the best chili cheese fries in
Compton is right in the mob Hood you
just kind of got to figure out how to
get to all of these places and get away
with it and when you go you you got to
like really just not have out on your
your stuff right like you would I'm I'm
past that people knew who I I mean
people know who you are yeah but I'm
saying it's been a long time they can
smell a [__] like people could smell
gang banging other gang bangers can
smell other gang bangers that's why if
they like hit you up oh where you from
like oh man uh where you who was your
mama where you live where you grew up at
like you know they smell out they could
tell yeah I mean I've always uh head
always tells me and I don't if this is
good advice or bad advice but he said if
I ever end up somewhere and I have a
couple of times where I was getting gas
somewhere and I called ahead this
happened like he posted it on Instagram
cuz I hit him and I was like yo I'm
right here am I good to get something to
eat I'm getting gas and he's like what
the [__] are you doing there yeah but he
head would always say he's like yo if
you end up somewhere and you get banged
on just start acting like real frantic
like you're in the middle of a crazy
fight with your girl and you got lost
like man my bad bro sorry man [__]
fighting with my [__] bro I don't know
what the [__] cuz that's a universal
masculine thing we all be like oh man I
just got caught cheating this [__]
tripping bro he like man she [__]
have me get out the car my bad bro do
your thing yeah yeah man my bad you know
that's what head said it's true it works
it work like just just act like you're
in the middle of a crazy fight with your
girl you don't know where you're at and
you know get on your phone and like it
should be all right yeah yeah yeah now
for the most part it's okay I mean gang
bangers the most underrated part about
gang banging is they're pretty
understanding yeah if they sober if
they're
sober like most humans that's like hey I
about say that's a pretty general
statement for the world but gang bang
and it get worse when you know you drunk
because you get superpowered and people
be charged up yeah like my wife when she
gets mad if she's drunk and mad it's
over it's over it's another level Latina
oh yeah yeah that's Spanish cuss words
Spanish cuss words yeah there's a lot of
Spanish cuss words I've been called um
okay so if someone gets your CD
physically and they look at the back you
have obviously got West Coast cam you
got sugarfree shout out to sugarfree the
legend I need you to help me get
connected with him sure I got you I got
you um but then you also have Samuel
Jackson and the Notorious BIG listed as
features yeah yeah yeah um explain both
I just feel like it's always weird when
you looking at a track list and and
somebody voice pop up who the [__] is
that and I just put that there like um
obviously on Spotify I didn't try to
infringe on their audiences but I wanted
people to know that that voice you hear
is gonna be biggies or this voice is
gonna be Mar Luther King or Samuel
Jackson or Cedric the Entertainer you
also have um the guy who plays Jesus um
in the music video for slink slink
Johnson yeah shout out to slink Johnson
he did a really good job on uh Fredy
Gibbs album too he kind of was like a he
did one of the skits on his album uh and
he did great on your music video yeah
yeah uh what's it save something for the
[__] for [__] something for the
[__] something for [__] yeah which
is um an ODed to
uh it's weird because right there's a
men with bedazzled anklets that and just
just straight men impeding on women's
beauty standards in the first place
completely top to bottom I tell them all
the time straight men Cyrus my shooter
over there got two earrings in that you
know what's funny that 30 40 years ago
that would have been look round at 20
years ago that's normal mhm when I was
growing up my dad used to always tell me
if you have an earring on a certain side
it meant that you were a gay yeah oh
yeah like the right side right and if
you have both it's like what girls do
yeah that's true that that used to be
that way that used to be that way then R
Kelly kicked that down cuz he had them
things him and AI you know what I'm
saying but no this album in general cuz
you're listen man if y'all don't follow
glasses on Twitter he's one of the most
frustrating entertaining follows ever
there are very few things that I I so me
and you it's funny because I'm getting
ready to redo the whole set and a lot of
my set is going to be dedicated I bought
a doggy style on vinyl the OG vinyl good
that's good and I bought the uh o OG
cassette I've have had three copies of
the C good a kid that's a good one but
you and I are very aligned with some
hip-hop opinions some very very some and
four out of 10 most of most of the ones
that we're very passionately dug in on
have to do with Snoop and have to do
with doggy style because doggy style is
the most important hip-hop album in my
entire life sure and it's the most it's
the greatest one of all hipop and I I
kind of have like a three album where I
could be like this this is my goat album
right it's IL mtic it's Doggy Styles
probably get rich of D trying in any
order that those could be one two or
three on sure Monday Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday whatever but doggy sty is the
most important in my life that's fair
and in my opinion Snoop Dog somehow
while being the most famous rapper in
the world by far still underrated he's
underrated yes agree how is this a
possibility by the way my bucket list
interview I hit his guy Kev once a mon
month and I'm like dude I'll go to the
it's my bucket list alltime interview if
I can interview Snoop I might cry cuz I
want to explain to him me getting doggy
style on accident changed the path of my
life but how is Snoop still
underrated how does that happen well
he's the greatest hip-hop artist of all
time right but if you favor certain
Styles maybe Snoop won't fit that style
so immediately he's from the West so
that's going to immediately take credit
from
the the Cornerstone of hip hop in New
York or the East Coast that's going to
be a Cornerstone issue that he's not
from the right East he's from the West
um his style is like a
oneof you know what I mean to me is like
a descendant of like short and LL kooj
super smooth you know what I mean but
you can see he's such a hip-hop kid like
First videos you can see the special ed
in his movements how he moved and how
smooth he was um I think the majority of
it is
one he's from the west coast and not
from the East two would probably
be he's
alive he's alive that's real real [__]
you know what I mean he's alive and
that's really important which is even
greater because you look at him now and
he's probably like
still the most
recognizable you know rapper on the
planet no I do say that I say there's
certain artists that if God forbid they
passed away would shoot to the greatest
of all and I really think think that
about Kendrick like I tell people like
oh yeah we we really kind of don't
appreciate Kendrick like we should CU if
he passed away tomorrow for whatever
reason he's the goat um he's at least
he's at least like solidified in that
conversation in the same way we talk
about Pac and it's really dope and I try
not to comment on dot because you know
dot is my friend and somebody I I love
to death you guys have done records
together way way deeper you know mean
this [__] really my partner but it's
like he's also a generation undermines
so I have to listen to a lot of younger
people tell me versus me giving my cuz I
I have [__] that I'm looking like you
Scarface you know I'm saying scarf it's
like as much as I love DOD it's like
Scarface you know me he raised me do is
like well I would just say cuz like we
put biggie in certain conversations
based on two albums when he was alive we
got two album that's them them albums is
[__] that well no those albums are
incredible but what I'm saying is if you
if if you look at just like if something
happened to died it it'd be frantic it'd
be frantic it it it would probably re it
would probably reshape hip hop at that
point permanently I think unfortunately
people sometimes when they
leave uh prematurely they get
appreciated more and I think we've seen
that happen a lot time and time again
over the last decade or or or or their
Spirit can be free to roam about the
cabin yeah cuz I think a lot of times we
don't get into like even with right I
always felt like people look at gang
bangers and feel like I can't relate
right even though like you know [__]
is regular human beings but they can't
relate and I think it became so
important for people to to get what he
was on when he passed away cuz it made
him mortal right people really look at
gang banging like like a he-man sport
like oh man if they die I don't care or
you know or they can't die or they did
something to die or they in prison you
know versus some dude just really
running a business and having a somebody
taking his life and I think there's
nothing more human than that so I think
that's what happened with him well back
to the Snoop thing I think what happened
with Snoop was when we look at things
through like um a biased
hip-hop you know I guess goggle CU for
whatever reason a lot of The Taste
makers in hip-hop over the years have
been very East Coast biased I mean yeah
from New York I think if you think of
like doggy
style I think snoop's early on
contractual [__] got in the way of him
probably being looked at in the same way
we look at NAS or I would even say Nas
because Nas had some issues with his
discography but let's say Jay-Z right
cuz dog I think dogf father was an album
I
enjoyed um but it wasn't doggy style and
then there was the kind of the
disconnection with death row and then he
went to No Limit and then the then that
first No Limit album was forgettable no
limit top dog was my [__] I love that I
love last the last meal was my [__] but
I think like it's it's almost like we
kind of lost some years of peak Snoop in
the way that we because obviously the Dr
Dre relationship
dissolves so that that mattered a lot
you know what I mean and then he has
this other run in the middle of his
career with forel the blue carpet
treatment Rhythm and gangster really
great Rec that we don't oh my God that
we just like forget about yeah even that
whole album he did was for real um was
it called Bush yeah yeah was dope as
[__] so I just think that like man for
whatever reason like we really didn't
get to really
enjoy like Peak Snoop Dog in the way
that we should have because of things
that were probably outside of his
control because there was the murder the
murder trial so so let's so let's
actually let's actually clear frame like
let's not talk about what we reading on
Wikipedia let's go by what really
happened right in 199 to we got the
first Snoop Dog album no disrespect to
Dr Dre The Chronic that's the first
Snoop Dog album fair enough shout out to
Dre Big Brother Snoop coming out party
he's on 14 of the 15 records he wrote
pretty much the record right that's the
first Snoop album The CME then doggy
style drops that's 94 right that's 93 93
okay then doggy style is such a big deal
was sales 870,000 albums in the first
week 890,000 the second week right which
50 came and did again right that
happens it's so impactful it forces a
change on the whole game it turned like
people get mad when I say this but Tupac
had to become more of a gangster rapper
because of this album yeah that's why
you go get thug life because of dog pan
you go get some 40 Crips yeah right you
ice cube has to become more of a
songwriter he was already a a decent
songwriter but he was a [__]
masterful pin MC but then he has to kind
of structure style to make more records
cuz dog is just destroying destroying
everybody everything on the radio right
boom so like he shifts the game like he
totally which is what a classic is he
shifts the game right and you just
boom then it's such an impactful album
one song spawns a whole another album in
'94 Murder was the case was the case
yeah that's so much the [__] it sells
triple platinum mhm right so that's 92
The Chronic right which is a snoop album
93 which is doggy sty which is obviously
snoop's debut 94 which is murder was a
case that's off a snoop album 95 his
group comes out yeah he's on seven to
eight of those records right dog food
yeah dog classic
album right I think I think it's a
classic album it's for sure a West Coast
Classic I think it's a classic album I'm
not I wouldn't even I'm not going to
debate that but we're going to get to
some debates about are yes we are but so
we got [__] 92 93 94 95 M Dre's leaving
so leaves so DJ poo steps in and
finishes attempts to finish dogf father
in '96 so what happened is we actually
did get to enjoy Snoop we got so Snoop
carried death R for sure but on his back
yeah you know what I mean and then Pac
came and that's why I always get upset
at that argument Pac was jealous Snoop
was jealous of Pac Man this [__] been
carrying the world's greatest most
impactful record label cash money is
probably Hip Hop's gra label but he was
carrying the most impactful label at
that time you know what I mean of all
time as far as impact impact yeah right
because it's this is the birth of
gangster rap at the highest yeah and
then the tree I always say PE like if
you look at the Dr Dre tree you look at
the Snoop tree look at the shg Knight
tree everything from there right so
right so he carries it on his back and
then finally Snoop right so poac comes
home and then boom now you got another
star it's like the Warriors and Kevin
Durant right you get another star you
you get this guy from the Thunder that's
Booker and Kevin Durant you know what I
mean like not like that but it's like
Katie from the thunder coming to the
Warriors right right Snoop Curry just R
every day right so boom and then right
so then he comes over and now you like
oh I ain't got to do all the work right
and then Pac comes and y'all give him
all the records y'all help y'all give
him the best beats y' and he puts up he
puts up them [__] go out there and finals
MVP what up 50 easy work but Snoop Steph
Curry but yeah right and he's just like
do your thing yeah and then he still has
to put out another album in 96 so we get
albums from Snoop in 92 93 94 95 and
dogf father in 96 so when Dre is leaving
Pac dies says Fran's Madness still a
snoop album is needed to you know carry
the banner because you got mavelli at
this point so those three records all
eyes on me mavelli and dogfather dogf
father produced by DJ Pooh does most of
the heavy lifting
they don't really get a chance to finish
it cuz we got to get this album out Pac
pass we got to get this album out we
always got enough of Snoop it's
literally just it's like survivors like
it's survivors guilt like he lives a
Survivor lifestyle where he survived the
crazy as [__] and he's right here so we
don't really appreciate him yeah I think
we just I think when we think of like
Snoop albums we think
of he doesn't get credit for the chronic
obviously but if you think about it the
the main song from The Chronic that we
celebrate who's on the song Snoop and
that's how it's been the whole time I
don't disagree even the dog fool what's
the main
song snoops onic yeah New York New York
New York New York yeah great great video
caused a lot of man just carrying all
the weight man so I would just say I
would just say like I just think that
like unfortunately and and and this is
kind of like a very convenient way to
look at things it's like damn the what
if of like if
they would have kept somehow kept that
nucleus together for like another two or
three years you know what I'm saying
like something I'm going say man it was
born out of trauma like death R was born
out of trauma it was born out of a
situation with e e you know what I mean
that probably wasn't a real enough
situation for it to to for them to break
up but it it it was born out of like
like all Street Urban culture you know
what I mean so we got what we got so we
just got to be grateful we got that four
years of incredibleness and a lot more
after that yeah cuz we did get the daz
album that was pretty cool great album
shout out to Daz man also one of the
greatest never I'm mad we never got the
corrupt produced Dr Dre album True the
excuse me the Dr Dre produced corrupt
album theat been crazy imagine that
drops even then what's crazy about
corrupt is like somehow like I think
streets is a mother is like I mean one
of the most underrated Fred [__] Fred
is [__] F Fred re oh that [__]
album is so hard ups and down like the
[__] Fred does crazy Fred is just nasty
and he really don't get enough credit
but sonically I had to call him probably
about 5 months I was like do you like
really C I don't know how are you doing
that but even his Sonic separate
completely different so I think Snoop is
just disrespected because he's from the
west and two he survived and I think um
his level of celebrity got to a place
where
most people stopped looking at him as a
rapper and almost started looking at him
more as like a cultural figure and and
like just an Entertainer like which is
why I say he's the greatest hip-hop
artist because when you understand
hip-hop is Street Urban culture there is
no greater representation of culture
than Snoop Dog yeah like Snoop is like
this nigga's a [__] that was [__]
walking on he's well I mean he's done
things that no artist like no rapper has
ever done and will never and we'll never
do 30 not not a hip-hop artist maybe
like a drake somebody who's not of the
culture no no he's not okay we not going
to do that he's not of the street Urban
culture you can't listen to music so is
Eminem not a hipop artist he's from
Detroit okay he from the ghetto okay
okay Drake is a from a middle class
Canadian neighborhood so if someone
comes from a middle class family they're
not no so you have so you're telling me
in your eyes you have to be from a
street urban community yes in order to
be considered Hip-Hop Hip-Hop is the
first genre of music forgive me cuz I
know everybody better listen to PO like
go you can't kick me it's not the point
I'm saying hip hop is Street Urban
artistic expression so
didn't well I mean we could probably
really nitpick this this discussion and
then I'm going kind of yeah I'm
going Drake's been popped saying Drake
is kind of popped that's a different
statement but to say somebody in my top
five okay some my top five I've had that
and I'm glad you said Kanye West did not
grow up in the hood and I've been
thinking this time he his mother was a
teacher and I've been thinking this
whole time I was like is he really cuz I
think as much as he's in my top five and
I appreciate him I think he is the
problem do you think Diddy is hip-hop
Puff Daddy no puff is an executive so
you don't think Puff Daddy is hip-hop no
I think puff put out hip-hop X but he is
hip-hop I don't know if he's responsible
for so much history Jimmy
a yeah but didy didy produce records
yeah really yeah has he really in the
same way Quincy Jones has produced
records yes really he puts the right
people together in the room forgive me
forgive me Diddy puff my bad look I
don't know but Kanye has been my my
greatest dilemma but if you think about
it right this is going to sound crazy so
Kanye is in my top five cuz I love you
know I think the world of Kanye there
were times I I've expressed it charl man
I think Kanye is a profit for living so
I think this much of him but if you
think about his first single he got into
a car crash great record like all
American car crash with insurance yeah
but what's wrong with that that's
nothing it's like Madonna could have
made that song that's not true yes it's
a middle class song about a man get into
a car accident with insurance so you're
saying there there can't be middle class
raps yes Drake is a fantastic rapper
fantastic non-stop is my [__] but that
don't mean they are hip hop Street Urban
culture now a lot of people disagree
with me some people like long as you
practice what them [__] do then you're
one of those [__] but you know how I
feel about that but my point is with
Kanye you would kick out like half a
hip-hop fast get that that you say you
aren't hip-hop fast because I'm going
tell you why because look what happened
to rock and roll mhm it ain't a [__] in
sight look what happened to
Jazz cuz soon as you start letting
everybody in the door guess who getting
kicked out first I don't think that's
ever going to happen in hipop guaranteed
they've tried it's h it's only been
there only been 50 years they they've
been putting out records for 40 it's
guaranteed to happen I'm not sure
there's uh you know what's funny is I've
always thought to myself like who's the
white you know like who's the white
that's like the white of whites in
hip-hop that like can actually make this
thing work like and like sustainable
long time let's get rid of Eminem cuz
Eminem is an alien yeah he's like a
anomaly in the world 30 40 years ago
Eminem would have been a punk rock here
it's Eminem by the way right if you were
to say it it's Eminem but but we had
this conversation
hip hop and punk rock are brothers Step
Brothers right right uh uh um same
father oppression and poverty different
mothers the area the Earth so you so cuz
cuz this is there's a lot of artists who
have families that went to college that
had middle class jobs a lot people from
together that went to college no middle
class middle class areas little yachty
yeah but would you really do you look at
little yachty and be like oh that's a
hip-hop guy yeah no you just only feel
like that cuz he raps no I think he I
think he's hip-hop for sure yeah but I'm
saying because he raps if he was think
he's also contributed a lot to culture
he's he wrote city girls act up he kind
of kicked off lowkey this whole fu yeah
but so did Jimmy IV so it's a lot of
other people but not in the same way
jimy I what song did Jimmy iven write
but don't that's not again you're you're
M there's people outside of the culture
who have wrote cultured songs okay let
me ask you a
question you're so cuz cuz I feel that
there has been and I'm not saying I know
of little yachty's hip hop I don't know
little yach there has been an uptick in
completely in what it's a complete
takeover of middle class people ever
since the blog era happened yes soon as
college kids started dictating what was
cool within Street Urban culture You'
seen the change because it became the
guys that they could deal with yeah but
to me that's still hip-hop that's not
that's just music hip-hop is the culture
like if you don't talk like us cure if
you don't talk like us how and there's
the five elements of Hip Hop no no no
those are expressions how you express
The Coachman so I just think that like
if you look at a guy I'm trying to think
of a guy you said the blog ER so I'm
just trying to think Kanye is the
greatest conversation and as one of my
favorite guys and as one of your
favorite guys yeah and Kanye is probably
the most influential artist of the last
I don't know 30 years who did he
influence middle CL
people Travis Scott is hip-hop middle
class people I don't even think Travis
Scots considers himself hip-hop that's
not true I don't I don't think so have
you did you listen to the drums on the
new album um again drums are not
exclusive to hip-hop I know but just you
know they've been having hard drums and
house and a lot of other stuff that
hip-hop birth okay so outside of but I'm
not again I haven't studied all of those
guys to say their [__] specifically I've
been saying this about Kanye and I think
that's why I mean Kanye did influence a
sound that kind of I mean him and Blaze
fingerprints all over the blueprint it's
really blink though it's who [__] well
[__] started it everybody start
following [__] okay so if you listen to
the blueprint right and then after the
blueprint everyone started sampling but
it's all based off [__]
okay this is it's important to know this
truth and and they are all I think
that's an opinion though no this is a
fact I don't think you can say that like
just blaze and Kanye weren't chopping up
samples before [__] was they wasn't
doing it the way they were doing it on a
blueprint before [__] that style that's
that sound that was birthed out of that
is [__] well the credit goes to
[__] I'm saying the general public would
credit the blueprint as the album that
kicked off a sonic wave of like people
sampling sure like high pitch samples
again again I'm with you I'm all in I'm
just saying there's a fact and then
there's a ignorance okay so are you
telling me Kanye is not hip-hop I'm
telling you that's that's been my
dilemma right because cuz he is hi well
this is the problem right Kanye West but
that doesn't mean anything that don't
mean first off nobody in [__] hip hop
put Marilyn Maro up on their [__]
wall as a kid what do what's I don't
understand the correlation between Kanye
and Marilyn Monroe cuz he talked about
putting up a poster cuz of Marilyn
Monroe on his wall what's wrong with
that why the [__] would a [__] from
where we from put up Marilyn Monroe on
their wall cuz they think she's hot no
none of us think she's hot that you're
speaking for a lot of people from the
ghetto I speak for all of us I'm sure a
lot of people in the ghetto would clap
her chees none of yes we would anybody's
but we wouldn't think she's hot it's too
many hot [__] sisters from that time
he Compares Kim Kardashian to her like
yeah but Kim K is is lovely you don't
you don't no she's not you don't think
Kim K is lovely no she was okay she was
a regular you think she was okay yeah
she was a regular they used to had him
in Glendale by the by the
barrel there was Kim Kardashians by the
barrel by the Barrel in Glendale that's
that's the normal fine girl in Glendale
When you go to the scene
I'm in Glendale a lot yeah I live in in
BB they don't have a plasticy well I
just don't see I I've seen I don't see
by the barrel I see them by the Barr
shout out to the beautiful Armenian
women who are in GL they're great
they're fine and they yes they are they
Kim Kardashian fine all of original Kim
Kardashian not this version I don't know
what's going on I'm not saying that
there aren't some Kim Kardashian fine
Armen a lot of them I'm just saying that
I think that you're uh you're
overstating your point no no no I'm
telling you the truth listen if if you
think about it right listen to every
other thing you loved about hip-hop
growing up right the struggle the the
the the ideas even how they party I
liked hey you know what I liked what
first of all I love doggy style sure and
the other album that really I like the
kind of like the
horror demonic Mystique of Bone Thugs
and
Harmony the Ouija are
you it was the melody that did it for
you though Mr and you know what else I
liked what they they had the best
Harmony since Beach Boys probably had
like fantastic Harmony I mean I can tell
you like from creeping on a come up to
East 1999 Art of War man God bone again
somehow criminally underrated super uh I
also really enjoyed Brother Lynch Hung
ly is dope I got that [__] for about
four zones I had to get dirty on brother
Lynch had a I always give props to his
album season of The Sickness it was a
very uh dark album where he talked about
eating children I like Lynch yeah I [__]
with Lynch Lynch is a nut but the point
I'm saying back to yay right here so his
brother Lynch hip
hop uh I would imagine so he's from like
a really [__] up getet on sack but him
talking about eating children but I
think he also created would not be the
something that a normal dude from the
hood would talk about well it's not I
mean he's like he's like um Edgar Allen
po also also Bone Thugs and talking
about playing around with a Ouija board
and talking to uh the you know that's
not that farfetched for people that's
not you you used a Maryland Monroe
poster on the wall I'm saying let's
start with Kanye growing up in middle
class area in Chicago so that's
different than bone and Bone and
Cleveland Brother Lynch and Sack them
them people are from places houses was
$13 for sure right so that's different
houses might have been $13 in Chicago
the houses is $13 in Cleveland right you
can get a house in Cleveland right now
for about $7,000
let me know where dlex I got you I got
you where bone grew up at yeah shout out
to uh the Cavaliers so so what my point
I'm saying to you is I'm not I haven't
came to a great conclusion it's Kanye
West so it's hard to challenge that type
of Legacy but if you think about it but
if you think about it right his first
song is about a car crash where he had
insurance but what got everybody is the
[__] black music he sampled in Shaka
Khan mhm that carries the story Kanye is
the best at using black music and
finding a place where he meets black
people at remember hip hop is almost
like you think Kanye makes he's a black
artist yes but but when you say black
right it's it's it's as simple as he's a
black man making music right but he's
not the first artist to sample black
artist no no but he's he's fantastic at
it yeah like when I tell you what he
does with that Shaka Khan and but if you
listen to a lot of his songs even the
depth of his struggle is very Eddie wins
but you know what it was what was dope
about Kanye is that his struggle was
relatable to white people to a lot of
people to mainstream America cuz if you
could talk about how you hated working
at the mall at the Gap that's like
main no okay but but but like imagine if
snoop's first album is about him talking
about having a problem working at the
mall what made but that's what made
Kanye different was he was a [__] pop
artist you could relate to him versus
you couldn't relate to none of these he
was not a pop artist he was making some
backpack dope rap [__] but he was
talking about not backpacked to work at
the mall because this is the the
minority of the of
everybody aren't in gangs and aren't
involved in street life and not but
whether or not they grew up around it
would you would you at least say that
most people period no matter what the
race of them or the or where they're
from are not tied up in street life are
civilians is that fair most they're not
from the ghetto
okay people from the ghetto have normal
jobs at the mall no they don't have them
at the mall but they do have normal jobs
are you trying to tell me people from
the ghetto don't work at the mall yes
but that's not that's a wild thing to
say that's a very wild blanket statement
you're you're pushing it further right
let's what I'm saying is that's not
where most of us working Kanye made an
made music for the normal person that's
what pop music is no pop music listen
this is what you got to understand is
that not what pop music is cuz for
everyday person no but you're trying to
you're you're essentially trying to say
well Kanye was making music for uh
privileged people who had normal jobs I
did not first off yes it's not you're
not privileged you have a normal job
that makes you mainstream American but
even people let's say from where you're
from right but that but but even then
now you're talking about I'm asking you
though so people from where you're from
right let's say your neighborhood yeah
what percentage of them are actively
throughout their life
practicing involvement in let's say
Street culture illegal activity gangs we
all talk the same way so that's I'm not
talking about talk I'm talking about I'm
talking about how you get your money the
lifestyle you live you can't pick the
part of a culture you enjoy right cuz De
La Soul is culture right but it don't
mean that it don't mean there's probably
people from your area who had to get up
and go to work and do their normal job
got homies that got jobs that Kanye [__]
and was like yo this dude's talking
about working a [__] overtime shift
at a retail store this is that's [__]
pop music no it's not that's normal
middle class [__] that's what pop
America is so you're trying to say Kanye
wasn't making hip-hop that's not what
I'm saying I have I told you I've been
having this dilemma in my mind to say
that so so you make a lot of blanket
statements then no I'm I'm giving you
really consistent statements consistent
considering all of your statements
according to your logic Kanye is not
hip-hop I'm thinking about it I've been
I've been on this play cuz I've been
saying for years he's hip-hop but then I
think about and I'm like that's why
black America's disconnected from him
right now they like well I think they
also might be disconnected because he
said some wild [__] no he did he said
the same [__] he been saying since the
first day and he has been wrapped up in
a very
unrelatable
culture whether it's the Kardashians
whether it's you know why huh cuz he
ain't that type of guy but he was that
type of guy no he wasn't he was just
doing it over Shaka Khan and the other
thing well okay
that's what I'm starting to believe I
was like he always been this crazy [__]
Kanye is like so so do you think Playboy
card's hip hop no okay I got to ask but
he got some dope [__] the first song but
all that weird devil [__] I had to slap
little cuz like all that ho ass [__]
they doing with the devil that'll be
cuby I don't like that yeah I know you
do I hate that you love you some little
Nas X though no no l Nas is cool cuz he
just fake gay I told you you going to
see one day it's going to come out cuz
fake gay what does that mean he's
playing for the money so you don't think
l no no I don't believe cuz is gay I
believe they paying cuz and he know his
play and he running his play why would
you not it's [__] who do it in
gangster rap it's [__] who do it like
they fake D
boys why would you not be fake gay for
money especially if you young why has it
more people been fake gay for money then
they it has been people fake gay for
money fake gay yeah l f f the gayness
easy you act gay for people like a fake
gangster rapper like a [__] who act
like he a gangsta but he's not I think
there's probably more fake straight
people than fake gay people I would
agree yeah I would agree for I for sure
would agree but that don't mean Lil nasx
is not straight I think L NX is uh is
gay I don't believe that and I think
it's he's gay facing you think he's gay
I know we talked about this last time
but I I just don't know if that's a
that's I don't know if that's the uh
that's that's what my that's what my way
if he really wanted to like lean into
something he would have just been the
country artist he couldn't he you know
that's not going to work no white folks
ain't [__] with that [__] bro they did
when Oldtown Ro no they
didn't I don't know money man where's he
from money man money man you listen I
don't I haven't I haven't so listen so
first off I can't talk about Travis
Scott but I think Travis Scott has
defined his sound but I think he defines
his sound as uh what is like Rave or uh
what's that rage rage no he's making hi
but he's defined his music Uzi defines
his music as rock and roll I think Uzi
defines himself as a rock star yeah that
makes rock music no he doesn't make rock
music yes but again this is my point see
see how you see how you laying claim to
that see how you won't let [__] be
nothing else but rappers cuz they Sno
dog's a rock star yeah but but no he's
not what do you mean he's not he's Snoop
Dog he's in the Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame he's in every Hall of Fame yes cuz
he's he's a hip hop star he's a rock
star he's a pop star he is the guy yeah
but but let me make my point for we get
lost listen yo what up guys we got to
stop the interview to tell you about our
folks at my bookie it's winning season
right now NFL we're in the thick of it
I've been doing really good on my NFL
bets by the way plus NBA officially back
we got playoff baseball it's going crazy
especially if you like to throw down
some of that money and do a little
gambling you got to head over to
mybookie uh this was DPE about mybookie
it doesn't matter if your team sucks my
team the Cardinals they're trash don't
matter I'm still winning on Sundays baby
all right at my bookie all right you can
use my bookie for your daily odd boost
same game parlays and take advantage of
the crazy huge prize pool contest plus
right now my bookie has a no strings
attached that's the important thing no
strings attached cash bonus that let you
deposit and withdraw quick that's free
cash no strings attached deposit take it
out and then go about your day or get in
on some of this NFL and NBA action baby
all right just use the promo code
bootleg when you sign up go to my book .
a use the promo code bootleg on your
first deposit and you'll receive up to
$200 in cash what are we talking about
no strings attached what my bookie use
the promo code bootleg all right maybe
you want to gamble on some NFL maybe you
want to get in on some of this early NBA
action maybe you want to get in on some
of this playoff baseball it's really on
you use the promo code bootleg and
receive up to $200 in cash that's right
try my bookie right now use that promo
code bootle
and you can grab um how about this man
there's some crazy odds going on and I
like this one cuz what you can do is you
can throw down on a potential Super Bowl
front runner and uh plus
38,000 on the Eagles and Chiefs on the
Super Bowl plus
38,000 if you put
$100 you win
$38,000 you're not going to get those
those odds anywhere mybookie.ag use the
promo code bootleg right now bet
anything anytime anywhere only with
mybookie plus we got to give a big shout
out to our family at King pom man we
love King pom over here on the bootleg C
podcast this is what's great about King
pom first of all it's all about that
organic no tobacco leaf this thing right
here is a boy look at that that's just a
leaf right there King pal they got
everything you need man they got these
cones with the squeez and pop tpin in
the flavors this right here is the uh
the dragon fruit we got the grape HD the
watermelon wav so many flavors what's
dope about King pal if you're in
whatever City you're in you could find
king palom at your local smoke shop your
local 7-Eleven all right I'm telling you
King pom you're not going to ever ever
experience a more cleaner more natural
more just great way to smoke which
you're smoking all right you stuff one
of these boys up with some flour uh and
and you just you're Off to the Races I'm
telling you you hit the tip you get hit
with that flavor and it's man it's
nothing like it the squeezing pop on
King pal is insane all right and they
got all size cones all right so go to
King pom man organic tobacc free leaves
of all sizes like this is uh this is a
this is look look we're talking about
all sizes here what are we talking about
what are we talking about here boys all
right go to King pom.com right now you
can order whatever you want man they got
accessories they got trays they got
Grinders they got ash trays they got
damn all kind of flavors of their leaves
everything 50% off when you use the
promo code bootleg that's 50% off order
whatever you want at King pom.com let's
get back to the interview I I haven't
studied none of those other guys so I
can't comment per se on yachty because I
don't know yachty story I don't know
Trav story I don't know them but I don't
think they Define themselves and I think
they will maybe yachty would be the
closest person that could consider
himself hip-hop or would well his dad
was a big photographer he did photos for
dead PR
uh but he didn't grow up like like from
what I understand he grew up like with
you know like a middle class kid yeah
and I'm not saying I don't I don't know
I had to really study it before I say
that Trav I think he defines his music
as something else and I think Uzi
defines his music and his existence as
something else but I think because they
use rap immediately everybody classifies
somebody black in rapping as hip-hop and
it's [__] [__] up if Uzi Uzi as
black people created rock and roll right
he can go in and find it as he want
that's his claim to rights you can't
look at Nirvana or no you and then say
he got to make music like that we did it
the first time so we could redefine it
the second time okay it's fair of him to
do that but what I'm saying
is back to the point we were saying in
my neighborhood being in in Street urban
life is not necessarily you know being a
criminal like there's a lot of people
like LL wasn't a criminal there's people
who grew up in the same cultur well what
I'm saying though is that there are
people who aren't criminals who maybe
they're they're gravitating they
gravitated towards College Dropout
because oh this is something different
I'm not disag this this is actually I
liked it as a criminal but that's not
the point I like Michael Jack I like a
like of pop artist but I'm saying like
if I like to me as somebody who was
woring a Best Buy when I was 16 I was
like oh [__] I get it this [__]
is rapping about working at a shitty
retail job bet you do get it that's my
point I'm saying so what I'm saying is
but I grew up I didn't grew up middle
class I grew up poor as Fu I know you
did cuz Phenix got some [__] crazy
sick ass poor places yeah they do yeah
sick that nobody talks about sick some
crazy [__] shout out the fix cuz they go
through some [__] nobody talks about it
that's true but the point I'm saying to
you is when we saying this it's
like everybody that grow up with us talk
the same way everybody who grows up with
us eats the same way every Everybody
grows up but that's not Universal that's
where you're at right but but that's all
Street Urban culture it's the way the
people in Atlanta are different people
in Gary Indiana are different ghetto
people in Cleveland are different every
ghetto there is no middle class culture
there only tradition in middle class and
in wealth there is no culture so
therefore how could you have hip-hop
somewhere where there's no culture so if
Drake let's say Drake for example shout
out to D do you think the Beasty Boys
are are hip-hop no they punk rock that
made a hip-hop album okay do you think
Licensed to Ill is hip-hop yes they made
a hip-hop album okay so that's hip-hop I
agree because but they actually punk
rock they started as punk rockers punk
rock and Hip-Hop right are step Brothers
okay Run DMC a what they're hip-hop
listen correct they're of course do you
do do you think that Run
DMC like obviously Run DMC is kind of
looked at as like the first like I would
would you say like pop hip hop group in
terms of like their popularity in terms
of popularity when we use the word yeah
yeah I guess to some degree
um would you discount them working with
AOS Smith because I don't think I think
you work with whoever you want to but I
think Hip Hop is more as much as Street
Urban culture is defined through crime
and and densely populated crime rid
neighborhoods it don't mean everyone's a
criminal I didn't say I didn't say that
was the case which was my point not
everyone's a criminal so I feel like you
were pretty much saying n where we're
from this is what we we we don't [__]
with regular Mall jobs no that we we're
we're denied Mall jobs that's not true
yes have you been in the mall yes I've
been in the mall in the worst areas yes
yes yes I got some of the my worst type
of friends working at the mall steal it
out of the back of a foot I'm not saying
that allegedly back in the day I'm
saying the poverty and the oppression
here's a here's a here's a here's a
Richard conversation but let me get that
point off I'm saying we're all the
cultures created through the crime the
crime happening to everybody whether you
involved or not you know what the crime
that is to education programs to where
the education programs are trash and you
don't speak great English so y'all make
up slang and y'all all talk the same way
it don't matter if cuz got a job at the
mall in the hood or if he's selling dope
we all talk the same we all got the same
lingo we all do the same thing I this is
the this is what I liken it too and this
is going to be crazy cuz you know you're
a white man in this conversation is
funny you're a [__] but you're a white
man the point I'm saying to you is
there's always been three black cultures
in America right or three the ideas of
three identities there's a slave you
know American slave culture right that's
where you get sold food that's where you
get all that there's a Freedman since
the first day black people been on this
planet especially in this country
there's been freed black people and then
there's been slave masters a smaller
culture of black people it's not a
culture it's a tradition of life that
really small minute of black slavers
right that's there small Freeman slaves
Kanye is a Freeman his whole
conversation is Freeman he has no idea
what [__] from where we from are
talking about that's why you'll say
something like slavery is a choice Kanye
reminds me of a kid that got to visit
his cousins on the plantation it was
like we need to leave here once this
weekend when I go home y'all go with me
that makes sense that's how he talks cu
cuz his mind and that's what middle
class does to you it creates a place to
where the world is Limitless the world
is not like like your world is not real
to them it's it's the upside down right
okay that's fair that's what hip hop is
but again because people want a piece of
it and it's like it's something seems so
cool they want a piece of the lingo they
want a piece of the get down but they
don't want a piece of the consequence
that's why I'm really careful with who I
say and who I believe represents me as a
ghetto person from hip hop now if I
start allowing somebody like Drake
forgive me Drake again shout out to the
homies it's no disrespect but if you
don't speak not one thing on what's
going on with black people in this
country not one stance not one why
that's been my biggest critique I don't
even care cuz he's Canadian right but I
I just I just feel like he doesn't ever
have an opinion on anything but except
now he's wearing rainbow Clips so you're
endorsing movements but you're not
endorsing the people that put you in
position
to be where you now yeah I I do think
it's like interesting that like why you
don't have shade for no why your shade
is for Jo but he he not first off a rich
Jewish man right bragging about being
rich to some [__] that come from the
ghetto like Joe butons that [__] is like
cringy whereas like well I just think I
mean I said this on Twitter the other
day I said
uh I don't think Joe Buton said anything
that was unfair or disrespectful and I'm
not mad and I'm not mad at
Drake being offended at his critique of
Dr I'm a little I'm a little mad at that
because I feel like Drake bro you have
to understand like people are going to
have an opinion about your music and as
long as they're not crossing the line or
they're not saying anything and he
should be able to have an opinion about
them but my thing is why does it go
right to what you have or money like
you're like Drake is actually a talent
talented accomplished MC record making
[__] monster yeah why go to money I
have a private jet and you have to take
first class flights because you're a
rich Jewish man right that's like being
a broke black person it's like that's
how common to to to the main ears that
sounds it's like you going to talk about
a [__] being broke it wasn't yeah it
wasn't necessary for sure so I'm not mad
at him but he could have talked about so
many things you know what I mean and
that's what hip-hop is it's bearing the
burden of Street Urban culture you have
to represent right see when you don't
have when you don't have to represent
nobody Jay could have never went out
like that because he represented Mars in
Brooklyn he had to that's the only way
he could Garner support Snoop could
never you you know another reason why
Snoop is such a fantastic hip-hop artist
he will never break crippin he defines
crippin how he wants that's what crippin
is all about you know what I'm saying
long as you don't break them that one
rule about no snitches you can do with
cripping as you please just don't make
nobody look dumb and Snoop has done a
great job of not making people look
stupid and he never broke away when you
don't have have to bear the burden of
culture when you don't got to represent
hip hop is all about representing the
people we talking about do they [__]
represent do do people from their
Community feel like this is our
spokesman like when I talk rest assured
any real [__] from watchs most [__]
from wats be like that [__] is all
right yeah [__] from la gonna be like
glasses is all right cuz I I have to I
can't do no sucker [__] how I'mma show
my face in the 60s how I'mma show my
face in a trades how I'mma show my faces
in the great streets how I'mma show my
face and East coasts if I go looking
dumb I have the burden of representing
ghettos that's what hip hop is LL had
the responsibility LL and Nas had to
represent Queens 50 had to represent
Southside Queens Jay had to represent
Brooklyn if you don't got to represent
[__] and you can still be successful
[__] you are not one of us if you can
embarrass us every week you don't think
that Drake represents Toronto no all
right not the streets I mean he
represents Toronto as the the Raptors
represent Toronto and he's their guy
like I think Drake my problem is Drake
represent black people right and we be
looking like cuz what are you
doing you know what I mean like what the
[__] cuz why would you do that but the
problem is when we try to hold him with
our ghetto respons he's not a ghetto kid
he don't come from the ghetto he don't
if you got to think morale and Street
Life create standards create
morals you know I mean the religion
excuse me and Street Life create morals
without it America is just like a dog
eat dog place right they [__]
up yeah I think we can at times be
unfair towards Drake because he is such
a just massive shining star in in
hip-hop I think that at times Drake does
things where I'm like okay you're like
being a little too emotional towards Jo
but and like to Discount him as like a
failed rapper unfair I I don't I don't I
don't really care about that I do think
though I what I care about is them
[__] hair clips see I don't I don't
care yeah if you go to Door why don't
you like the hair clips because why you
Snoop Dog had had had a lot of [__]
going on with his hair and show the
sugar free yeah but they ain't putting
rainbow hair clips that's a purpose he's
doing a lot of things on purpose to do
certain things and I'm asking you why
you ain't stood up for no [__] if you
going to stand up for somebody who you
going to represent you who's he
representing you think he's representing
the the AL boys you know he is and
that's his thought I don't think so then
why would you put rainbow hair Clips in
your head why does Rainbow got to be
exclusive to something that that it it
ain't a God it's just what if he bought
a pack of hair clips and they came in
multiple colors why does everything have
to have a specific meaning or agenda
attached to it Drake's hair clips don't
mean anything except for their hair
clips you really believe that do you
think Drake purposely said nah give me
the rainbow pack yes no he's that crazy
you don't believe Dr Drake is like one
of the greatest Minds like Kanye West
inop tell you something not see the
problem is is let me just say this the
problem
is certain like in 2023 for whatever
reason we always have to put a meaning
or stick some sort of agenda to
something that it don't got nothing to
do with because we all know it means
something it doesn't it does it's just
hair clips no it doesn't it's not are
you serious it's not if I were so you do
you think Drake's hair clips are him
endorsing a certain lifestyle yes really
yes and it's the mainstream thing to do
what does that mean that's the thing to
do at a main level across the world
that's what every pop artist would be
doing across the world that people not C
this not by accident you think this [__]
by this [__] is brilliant like Drake is
so what is Drake's agenda with his
colorful haircut now we going to go into
some details but obviously what what is
your uh perceiv obviously endorsing
right which I don't care about that but
my thing is the [__] who made you
famous These [__] In America these
ghettos cuz we pushed CU like he
couldn't just be a pop star and be that
we pushed C the ghettos push C we said
the females the black women from the
ghetto push CS you ain't said nothing
about nothing happening to these Sisters
You Ain't posting nothing that's
happening to these sister you not saying
nothing about no [__] and I got let
that go cuz you was Canadian I'm like
you know what he don't have to give
[__] what happened to American [__]
I don't disagree with you sure on that
point cuz I do think at at certain
points in time it'd be nice if we knew
what Drake thought about I don't know
George Floyd or ban Taylor I'm not even
asking that because most pop artist or
or or you know he lives here a lot yeah
like there's a lot of turmoil going on
with our political system just any sort
of opinion and I'm okay with that but
like you said he's Canadian yes what do
you think about Justin Trudeau Drake
facts facts facts what do you think
about the Canadian truck driver who I'm
not mad because that's a hip-hop
responsibility okay okay but so I think
that's separate than you thinking that
there's an agenda with his hair clips
you missing a point of somebody that's
so brilliant to know not to speak on
something he's so this [__] him and 40
are some of the best scientists I ever
seen in the music business like when it
comes to creating records marketing and
understand how to Market Dr like Michael
Jordan right like Michael Jordan
purposely has said Republicans and
Democrats buy both my sneakers why would
I take a stance on any of this publicly
because then I I kind of and Drake's
kind of the same kind of guy yeah but
but Drake Drake appeals to everybody and
I don't think he wants to [__] that up
and and I'm not mad at that but my thing
is right that's why you know who else
does that pop
stars yeah I mean there's also artists
there's no hip-hop artists that do that
we won't even let them go we won't even
Nick if you try that if you try that and
you represent us it's a problem wait a
minute you're not going to speak up Thug
say something like oh we ain't talking
about that [__] we talking about young
[__] they was asking Thug about the
boy that got killed Mike uh in Ohio
what's brother yeah yeah um Mike uh
Michael Mike Brown Michael Brown m brown
Michael Brown and it was like yeah you
know was on a red carpet he like you
know how you feel about Mike Brown like
oh man we ain't tripping off that old
politics [__] we out here getting [__]
fell apart oh my God you [__] and
this [__] is a [__] who do drugs he I
don't even think we should even really
want his opinion cuz he go through so
much mental [__] and be high you know
yeah yeah you're not going to look to
Thug for political views but he still
has to cuz guess why he is from the
ghetto and Atlanta and we like you
better talk you better speak for us and
that's the responsibility of hip-hop I
don't give a [__] if it's tribe De La
Soul anybody you are responsible for
speaking for us in Hip
Hop okay so and if you don't we look at
you funny but the only people we don't
worry about is people that ain't hip hop
so what's the issue with uh with the
hair clips nothing I have no issues with
it I'm saying this is I'm asking you
this is the first so you are officially
purp your stance is he's purposely from
the nails the hair he's going to keep
going okay so do you you think Andre
3000 was doing that in 9697 when when
when he was wearing
certain I just think he got Erico [__]
and that [__] is some [__] okay Drake
ain't got no Eric bad [__] what about
Thug when Thug wore address on his album
cover yeah I think Thug is from Atlanta
where the street Urban culture is tied
into homosexuality that for some reason
nobody in Atlanta talks about it's like
right there like I've never seen a
bigger demographic of gay black folks in
the ghetto like Atlanta never seen that
do you think it's possible Drake just
got a bag of hair clips no zero chance
okay he's too smart he's too smart to
just do something and don't have no idea
it's impossible it's it's impossible 0
0% 0% 0% not even a half a perc chance
he just put some hair clips in his hair
and they happen to be different colors
no zero chance what zero
chance he's Drake Drake is brilliant dog
there's a confusion Drake is [__]
brilliant dog him and 40 together them
[__] could put [__] together sh or 40
the producer 40 the producer like he
could come with [__] bro they could put
[__] together like some of the [__] they
be doing music I be like [__] like you
know what I mean cuz you got to catch up
to this [__] and it's like [__] like
this is how smart they are he's a
marketing [__] machine you know what
I mean he knows
well I think that you're you're reaching
I understand why you feel that way cuz
it would actually mean you would have to
be accountable for decisions you make no
and we love a world where we could just
make people unable but in Hip Hop we
have to be accountable I just think not
everything famous people does has an
agenda attached to it I know because you
which it don't make sense because you
would think that some of these people
are some of the greatest marketing Minds
ever and you would think that they would
accidentally do something even though
they've been controlling the narrative
for 20 years okay Switching subjects
shout out to Drake yeah shout out to
Jersey you had a song that was called
Tupac deserve to die no Tupac must die
or Tupac must Must Die sorry music video
was dope uh was about four years old now
5 years old now it's four years now um
what are your thoughts on uh Kefi D's
arrest yeah uh he's obviously been doing
a bunch of interviews over the last five
six years just kind of I mean holding
nothing back in these interviews which
is kind of crazy it ended up biting him
in the ass in a real way um would it
just as a someone who you know made that
song Someone who is a fan of you know
hip-hop and what happened and not a fan
of what happened obvious obviously but
um I mean you did have a song obviously
I'm just what I'm saying just kind of
what's your thoughts on on uh on the
Tupac arrest uh I need to really see the
discovery I need to see the evidence I I
what's crazy because they did they had
to have arrested him because they had
because they did go and raid the house
and I think that's more about what
happened after that like I need to see
the discovery I need to see what how
what led to this arrest because I don't
think it's the interviews I think the
interviews could create a situation to
get a warrant right but I don't think it
could lead to an arrest I agree with you
on that so they had to something
happened something happened where they
had to and I need to see that before I
really yeah cuz the interview I mean
like you said the interview could have
resulted in the raid like the the
warrant to go kick the tour down that
that get you a raid for sure yes now
outside of that it ain't going get you
no they had to they had to spin the
block and then go arrest you something
happened so as far as that I don't quite
know um I don't want to see nobody in
jail you know what I mean not not like
what what sh Knight said Suge said I
think he said he grew up playing Pop
Warner with Kefi D or yeah I just don't
want to see nobody in jail because I
understand he would not wish jail on
anybody yeah I I know the consequences
if I do something so again Justice looks
a lot different for me than it does to
other people right um so whatever got to
happen got to happen you know what I
mean but I would love to see the
discovery of what what really led to the
arrest you know I mean cuz I didn't
think it was going to be able to happen
but the raid created one moment and then
the way they do the grand jury out there
is like it can be going for a year
like you could keep bringing [__] back
like is this enough well the thing is
this right if it is proven that he was
in the car isn't that enough to put him
in jail for two yeah yeah
but I don't think you can use the
interviews as a way to say no no no no I
think I think they have something else
and if they and whatever that something
else is put him in that car that night
so in California it becomes felony
murder I don't know what it looks like
in Nevada but I'm sure they got
something similar yeah so I mean they
they sent he The Mastermind which again
I need to see how is he the Mastermind
you know what I mean because I I think
ke listen the reality is Kei was some
[__] like Kei was a rich [__] the
reason the Southside Chris was the
richest Hood in cter when I was a kid
him cat named think they was like super
rich when I was younger yeah so he just
wasn't just some random dude from Vegas
or people that yeah he was actually he
was a real factor and if you and them
dudes I mean this is any gang in La man
if you jump on on somebody they can
pretty much bring your hat to you if if
they if they decided for that to be
their purpose it don't matter who it is
yeah long as you around here I mean my
thing is is it it's it's just nice to
see that they didn't necessarily give up
what's crazy is when I think about it
right it's it's for 27 years um and then
he moved to
Nevada after you know what I mean like
and I think he been there you know what
I mean but
it's it's a it's a it's a weird thing
going on about the whole situation so
well I mean I see I see some speculation
about people's involvement I ain't
buying a Puffit like I can make a joke
anyway but there's no my issue with that
is cuz there's no way he could owe them
a million dollars and then puff be alive
for a year and they doubling back out
here and they ain't got that money yeah
that just I don't believe that but I
think that made the story interesting
enough to tell the story and it puts
somebody else as the head in the story
you know I mean I don't quite know why
that would be the story I mean and then
I could just be wrong cuz like well
because there was that I just don't
believe it I think there was a but you
know what's funny there was that LA
Times article that was written that
insinuated puff was involved what's
crazy is there's no way I could think of
puff like that but if you think about
puff puff has became Su lately he is the
sh of the hipop that [__] is firing
niggga [__] up and he have jumped on
jcole he him and J Cole got I don't know
if this is I don't know if this is true
not but I heard do you remember that guy
Choppa CH who was on making the band
sure I heard when he was having issues
with with Diddy and I don't know if this
is true but I've heard this from a
couple of
people puffy bought the house across the
street from choppa's
Mom just to [__] with him like I I own
the house across the street from your
mom like I always have eyes on when your
mom that's crazy cuz puff was like I
don't know man puff I can't believe it
though cuz puff puff seems like an all
right guy but I don't know cuz you know
what I mean like n for sure I mean
listen I met him a couple times his son
always seemed like an all right guy like
I don't also seems like the guy you just
never really [__] with for whatever
reason like people kind of know not to
[__] with puffy yeah but I don't think
it's out of a fear that puff is going to
get at you I think it's just like puff
is so [__] awesome yeah like why
would you want to burn a bridge with
with Diddy yeah you know I mean I never
got like I've never in my life saw puff
and thought to myself even when he was
arguing with the man from power on the
corner cuz and he was talking I was like
that that was me and puff you talking
about when uh he was dressed like the
Joker yeah I'm like man I had a cuss
puff ass I had a fire puff should he did
that because I just I see puff is such a
responsible man I just can't see him
wanting to throw his life away by put
and he also has so much like going on
you would be like Puff's not stupid so
he's he's calculated he's and then I
can't see the South sides letting him
get away with a million doll debt for
all that time that that doesn't make
sense that ain't going to even last not
and these [__] have like when I tell
you these [__] had some money man when
I was growing up them [__] had money
I'm talking about real money they was at
a [__] Mike Tyson fight true which
you know what I mean these [__] got
some money in the 90s that's the the
ticket of the S there's no way I could
see them letting cuz get away with o
them that kind of money and ain't
nothing happen to cut they have been
tearing his ass up I I I I wonder if
this will
motivate uh any sort of resolve in the
biggie murder and I don't think it will
because I think the LAPD was obviously
involved off duty cops Etc I just think
the biggie murder was a professional hit
and it's just different yeah I I think
it was a professional hit and I think
for whatever reason it would have impl
it would have made the LAPD look really
bad had they solved it properly but even
then the F could come in I just think
it's hard to prove what happened like
cuz it was so done professionally yeah
the the the the poac [__] is different
like we heard about that [__] in real
time like this is really I mean Dev
[__] just jump baby Lane like you you
heard that in real time when it happened
that night then you heard Po got shot
you could put two and two like it was it
makes sense there it was one one event
affected another event and it an effect
situation thing around normal [__] that
happens the big [__] surprised everybody
none of us thought none of us heard
nothing about big [__] was a no none of
us even heard nothing about who did none
the big it was a pay to hit yeah yeah
like that was like a real job yeah so I
I don't I think it's just different
um why don't you think Kanye has a
classic album I never said that well you
said wait said no one has four classic
albums in hip-hop oh I I don't know why
the tweet I saw I thought that by the
way you're wrong but uh no one has four
classic Al hiop again y'all keep making
Classics just [__] you like or [__]
that's really good four Kanye's four
College
Dropout late registration late
registration is not a class it's his
best album that's not don't mean it's
his a classic a classic shifts the game
it's not like like late registration of
graduations are Ploy off a College
Dropout they're not different things
they're not that's not true graduation
is way different it's not it's just he
sampling music he sampled that don't
mean nothing it it don't mean nothing it
was the same [__] Classic Albums no my
my beautiful D Twi fantasy is a classic
I'm not even going to listen I could
take that greatest it might be the
greatest album ever no it might be no
all right no College dropouts a classic
yeah and if you want to talk about
changing stuff 808 heartbreaks which I
can't stand and what yeesus no but I do
totally enjoy yeesus a real Kanye fan
Jesus made Travis Scott possible listen
I'm not disagree and Travis was very
much instrumental into the making of
that album you're not going to hear any
debates with me about props for ye I'm
just not going to jump off that's not a
classic album I can ask I can ask
classic I think I think late
registration and graduation are Classics
I think Kanye
his first five albums are classic that
don't even make sense somebody dropped
five classic albums in a row just think
about what that would be 100% no no yeah
don't even make sense Kanye West did no
no he's got the greatest discography in
hip-hop history I wouldn't even even I
wouldn't even mind arguing that like I'm
okay with that but he don't got five
[__] Classic Albums you know who else
has four who Outcast no
yeah God damn it y'all just make
anything a classic what are you talking
about bro listen a classic don't mean
you really like it or it's really good
this is by the way this is your
definition of a classic mine's is the
authority figure in the conversation
okay as a product okay so you think
Outcast doesn't have four
Classics look if somebody I said no one
in hip-hop has four class not a soul not
a soul and I think to to hip-hop fans
this Kendrick has three I'm not even
going to be first off I came the fact
that [__] was throwing dot in the
conversation was great I couldn't I was
like it was like I got five I was like
no no no Kendrick has three I think it I
think to be determined on his last album
even though I really enjoy I still
listen to it a lot I still I still
Listen to It's not to be determined no
no no you that's fair I wouldn't put it
in the to pimpa Butterfly damn or good
kid Mad City conversation I don't even
think people give damn to correct credit
so it's hear you say I agree I think
those are the three though but but I
think when you say classic like I think
there's certain albums that are classic
IL Matic has been regarded as a classic
doggy style right doggy style a class by
what in your opinion what's the better
album The Chronic or 2001 2001 yeah well
I like the I like The Chronic because
the chronic has these really important
joints yes but 2001 if you listen to now
masterful yeah it's a masterful I just
worked out to 2001 like a month ago I
just played it and I was like Straight
Out of Compton is a class Eddie Griffin
his skits on 2001 are so fire yeah n Dre
has always been Fant see your mama was a
hoe yeah we get [__] oh God yeah that
was crazy okay so yeah but no I was
saying no one in hip-hop has okay I
think I misunderstood the Tweet thread
that I might have saw you reply to cuz I
thought you I thought you were saying
that uh Kanye didn't have any Classic
Albums which I was just like there's no
way you I'm really careful with cuz I
know you love give Richard D tryan
Classic hell yeah that's [__]
fantastic but I'm saying does Eminem
have a classic I don't know I have to
think about it Mars LP that would be the
one or
show it's it's probably Marshall M LP to
your definition I think Eminem Show is
the better album what would but but fix
is scarface's classic yes made is a
better album I like the diary too and
the diary is dope as [__] and a touch
and I think Untouchable is his best
album fix is a classic
album fix has my favorite Nas verse ever
my favorite Nas verse ironically is on
We Major oh on on yeah my that between
us between me and you whatever the [__]
that record is on the fix Jesus Christ
Nas went the [__] uh uh that verse on We
Major is crazy is is Victory lap a
classic I think it's been deemed they
went back and got it right um I don't
think it was a classic when it was first
released but I think it didn't get
appreciated but doggy style the same
thing happened with doggy style the same
thing happened with there was a few
records that one thing I give a hip-hop
credit is they will go back and write
their wrongs they did that with
reasonable doubt they did that that's
fair because I remember blueprint being
the first one everybody thought was
class everybody double back and I
remember having Reasonable Doubt
thinking that then now they got it right
right because that's been the person
that's come up a lot as Jay and I'm a
die hard jay face Snoop scarf what's
Outcast classic album to you aliens at
aliens yeah I think it's qu and I if
you're going to pick one I'm not mad at
that see Outcast is like that weird
group to where so many things is so
possible with them and they now have the
greatest selling hip-hop album ever yeah
just passed uh Eminem Eminem show it's a
double CD though true so it's gonna get
counted twice but yeah whatever you
remember those days when like eightball
was dropping triple albums like lost
that it was like yo if you did if0 was
doing that [__] crazy if you just did
333,000 your platinum yeah yeah that's
pretty slick and then [__] was
dropping two albums on the same day who
was here oh I just was talking to Insane
Clown posi they were here violent Jay
yeah and he Jay is dope shout out to Jay
yeah he was cool he was very
uh you know I got uncles like like him
that that done a lot of dope in their
life and are just very like he was he
was just very he was jittery such a cool
dude though super nice super jittery and
we would talk and I'd ask him a question
and then he would just go off on like a
random tangent about something unrelated
to the question but them drugs
connecting different brain he was so
cool and I'm always real tough on jugal
cuz I think for the most part they have
really bad uh um they're not good at the
upkeep of their personal hygiene but you
know what it is man jugal is like I
always felt like they was the ghetto
white people oh yeah but the most but
the most ghetto white people but that's
why I actually clicked with them yeah
because I mean listen there's ghetto
white people and then there's like The
Jug The Jug he my [__] I love the
[__]
yeah I don't know that's just my people
I don't have no idea I love I did the
[__] uh you did the Gathering the
Gathering oh so you went to the
Gathering yeah J and them GA did you see
the uh did you see the the the [__] tent
or the drug Bridge even know there
people just [__] I seen a drug what
it smell like didn't I didn't get close
enough but I don't think it SM
like I'm saying I love them
[__] I don't know why cuz they
My People The Jug are so funny cuz like
I I posted and I've always given up my
because I actually think
ICP on a business model standpoint yeah
are pioneers in hip-hop yeah I think
that what they did with their
merchandising I think Tech 9 gets a lot
and I Tech knows I feel this way Tech
gets a lot of
credit he knows that yeah I think Travis
had did Travis had has done a really
good job on improving on that model
daily improving improved on kind of what
ICP had had going but I think I think I
think for whatever reason IC
their
marketing and just their business model
as hip-hop artists like when I was a kid
they were the only kind of hip-hop group
where you could go buy their shirt and
Spencers like there was ICP jerseys
white man Hot Topic white some [__]
could happen but I'm saying it's like
it's like they kind of they push they
pushed the line they they to me they
they pushed the line of like if you go
to a concert we're going to have 100 SKS
that you could purchase yeah we're going
to have shoelaces we're going to have
all that [__] A lot of that [__] is
brilliant like them [__] is
brilliant you know I mean them
[__] is fire they just insane
so when did you first link with The Jug
World cuz you were signed to Suburban
noise which is kind of an offshoot of
that world I was managed by Suburban
Noise Okay that was like cotton mouth
Kings yeah uh Kevin Zinger Sr the boy
that's popping there shout out to him
uh they got that whole anti to me that
[__] is a dope movement where they have
like uh uh uh Adam coun yeah him and I
have had words online that's funny Adam
it's another guy Tom McDonald mhm and
there another guy that was from this
group um kind of Buffy white boy dope I
got a song with him just pissed me off I
I'm not think his name yeah but but
that's he was a part of a group
initially Struggle No it was it was real
Pi the name of the song was called real
Pi
uh God damn it I'm losing my [__]
mind yeah but I like that movement it's
funny because I feel like they moving
into such
a offset movement you I
mean what the [__] is going on why am I
not freaking this
out um that's not to say much though but
yo what's I need to figure out who
you're talking about uh real Madchild
Madchild oh yeah he used to be a part of
uh that I did the song with the group
though Swollen Members Swollen Members I
did a song with Swollen Members because
can right which is dope right I did a
song with swollen members and I like
Madchild me and Madchild still [__] I
put child in that world I know but so to
me cuz he's Canadian like you
automatically going to see it
differently no it's not that I think um
they had a label called battle ax
records I could be wrong about but it
was like they were like really like some
indie backpack like hip-hop vinyl like
you went and bought their singles back
what you think of Tom and them Tom and
and and and Adam I personally I'm not
too mad at Tom I've seen some of his
I've seen I was actually kind of
interested in his business model cuz I
saw a video coming out I'm like a music
industry nerd so I saw a video come
out or some sort of something came
across my timeline that he had sold a
certain amount of
units but because he sold them the way
he did that they didn't count it towards
his billboard sales and that had they
counted his billboard sales properly he
would have probably had like the number
one album in the country or something
right so I watched a YouTube video that
he put up explaining and showing how
much he actually
sold and um my homie Dax did a song with
him and Dax records here that's my
friend Dax is the brother that's like
the the brother that's super active yeah
he he's got like a country songs [__]
he's got yeah yeah I saw Dax before um
so I know they've worked together the
the uh Tom McDonald dude is Canadian
yeah Dax is Canadian okay um the other
guy Adam Adam coun this is the thing
that's weird about Adam coun me and him
have had our words and I've said that
his music is horrible I don't really
think like this my
thing anybody who and and you could I
this dude like made a record saying the
nword over and over for shock value sure
sure you saw the video yeah it's the one
where you talking about trailer trash
how our experience could be same and and
I get the I get it sure but you
understand but I was just like bro like
this he might have gaslighted the [__]
you f right and I just feel like the
somehow and I I could be categorizing
what he does un barely I could be but I
think the Leaning into the Maga
world for
clout is very like so you don't
genuinely believe he believes in the
[__] it's not that I think that if like
your musical identity is your Maga like
and I don't and listen to be fair to
this guy cuz I just talk I just talked
to Jelly Roll who's one of my jell is
dope well Jelly's one of my closest
friends in music we're dope I've known
jelly for white boy jelly shout out to
jelly cuz close to a decade you know um
yo we got to stop the interview again
and tell you about our folks at Odd
Socks baby that's right shout out to odd
Soxs man the most comfortable socks in
the world they've been riding with us
since day one um and let me tell you
something man Christmas time is is
really sneaking up um oddsocks
official.com use the promo code bootleg
save 20% off at checkout they got the
crazy licenses check out these Naruto
socks [__] fire little sponge boob
socks you know what I'm saying how about
this how about the how high movie socks
they got the WWE they got the
[__] Cheeto socks you know what
I'm saying shout out to the
[__] Cheeto socks they just
dropped their Monopoly line too I'm
waiting for them to send them to me Amad
send me the Monopoly [__] buddy all
right also the odd Sox Basics these are
my favorites they're just normal just
you know the most comfortable socks
you've ever put on your feet is really
what they are get them black white red
[__] tie-dye whatever you're into and
they got the underwear baby little
Reese's boys let's go oddsoxofficial
decom use the promo code bootleg they
got South Park underwear too all the
licenses WWE Scarface Breaking Bad South
Park Power Rangers Monopoly Coca-Cola
they got it all use that promo code
bootleg and save 20% off at checkout
also want to give a shout out to our
sponsor uh much love to our good Folks
at Blue Chu that's right we talk about
it all the time on the podcast when you
go to Blue .c right now you can get your
first month for free a lot of people ask
well what is blue and does it work well
blue it has the same active ingredient
as Viagra and Calis the only difference
is you don't have to go to the doctor
it's all online you go to blu.com you
get your [__] handled over there and
then they get you handled by sending you
a month for free when you use the promo
code bootleg blu.com promo code bootleg
try out blue chw it'll have your uh your
dick harder than it's ever been it's
like trigonometry in high school real
hard you know if you're dealing with any
sort of erectile
dysfunction uh blueo will have you right
like I said same active ingredient as
viagran Calis minus the awkward doctor's
appointment everything's online and if
you're asking well I don't know man I
just don't know try it out for free for
a month they'll send you a month supply
for free right to your doorstep in
discret packaging blue chewable form
it's in a little it's a little chewable
man you take that thing down and then
you go to Pound Town take your shorty to
Pound Town godamn it bluechew.com use
that promo code bootleg try it for free
for a month let's get back to the
interview and I told jelly the last time
I saw him I said hey I know you're tight
with that dude Adam coun and I don't
want to have like any real beef with
somebody that you're friends with so I
was like if you ever want to put me on
the phone with him like I wouldn't mind
just cuz we went back and forth on in
our YouTube comments and I I mean I
don't think his music's very good but I
I can't equate what he
does because he he's got whole albums
with my boy struggle and struggle's a my
boy like I love struggle struggle is a
talented guy so I really I think I might
have unfairly equated what he's doing
with what some of these real Maga
rappers are doing CU there's like real
sure guys who you can see they taking
advantage of no they're literally their
entire identity is they do Maga rap it's
like a sh a sub genre of music that is
strictly based on [__] black lives
matter uh
Trump Trump trump what's the what's the
jerk off's name from Florida that uh
Ronda Sanz no no no the rapper um forg
Auto blow who who used to be signed used
to be signed to Thomas Jones and was a
[__] wannabe Street rapper in Tampa
when I lived there and now all of a
sudden he is literally the face of magar
rrap to me that shit's corny super corny
and then there's like so I don't I think
I might have unfairly put those two guys
in the same Lane as to where I don't
think Adam Calhoun's music I think I
might have unfairly judged it also he
was beefing with my boy
casy um shout out to casy so I might
have unfairly judged him I'm not a fan
of his music I'm not a fan of like and
and this is and also I'd like to point
out it'd be like if there was somebody
waving a Biden flag in their rap songs
you'd be like what's
happening like who's who's making Pro
who's making Pro Biden rap music ask you
that question every last pop artist
breathing no no no I'm talking about by
name we're I mean listen I can pull up
well there some of these songs and the
the the hook is is like Trump Trump
trump magga magga magga yeah but that's
because it's counterculture it's Counter
Culture very much counter anything
counter cult even when hip hop would use
Trump's name as a way to establish the
conversation of wealth right for Trump
was take over the world on my Donald
Trump sh Trump was always counter cure
uh I'm Donald Trump and the y t and
white ones the conversations money yeah
I mean [__] Donald Trump was on
Method Man's uh second solo album toal
2000 so so again Trump has always been
counter cultured just where you place
him so my whole thing is this if I would
look at a rapper the same way if they
did an
AOC uh aosta Cortez the the the Congress
lady from Yeah Yeah from New York if
someone did a song that was like waving
her flag what about if somebody did a
Barack cell Like My President is Black n
that's hard cuz that's history it's the
first black president what are we
talking about by the way great song
shout out to jezy that was my be too
that's my favorite jezy album the
recession great album that's classic
great album but what but I guess what
I'm saying is like is that classic is
the recession of classic yes to me it's
a classic to me I don't think it's I
don't think it's it's higher on the
classic tier than uh than than thug
motivation 101 it's not a classic I like
the recession me too I don't think it's
more of a classic than it's not a
classic all to be fair it's not a
consensus classic it's a classic to me I
think we could all have personal classic
or you just like it no but I think to me
it's a classic to me but I would say I I
break down Classics from different
perspectives one would
be what I call consensus hip hop
Classics to where if you said that
album's a classic nobody's going to say
[__] to you nobody going to say that
about graduation you going to have some
conversations in hip-hop okay so that's
a that's that's a that's to me when I
think of Drake he don't have a good kid
Mad City the closest thing he's got is
take care you know what's funny I just
had that conversation somebody said that
I think I was like I probably not but I
I'm not I think Drake's best album is
Nothing Was the Same and I actually
think that album is damn near Flawless
and I think we don't give that album
enough flowers cuz nothing was the same
as I think Drake is fantastic at making
music man so I I don't I think I think
Drake but I just don't know if he's ever
adjusted
culture yeah I mean I get you I think
unfortunately I think the last like five
years I feel like he's been just mailing
it in even then CU I actually enjoyed
you know what I enjoyed about Drake was
when he did the EDM album I think Drake
always got some Cuts so it's hard to
really always got some m i see I can't I
never listen to Madonna so I don't know
that you got to go [__] with Madonna bro
and it's hard not for me I'm telling you
and they get mad I don't think 80s music
is good 80s pop music is [__]
terrible I'm not mad at that it all aged
horribly it sounds like [__] it's corny
as [__] keep all your just can't
wait I like 80s metal hey give me 80s
metal Metallica that's not bad give me
[__] you know Van Halen is in the 80s
yeah I mean Van Halen's not metal that's
like pop rock that's like Drake of
rock I would say like Judas oh met they
got big guitars yeah mega death um
pantas I got some [__] in the ' 80s so
at that point Guns and Roses is the king
of metal well Guns and Roses was pop
rock and that was the early 9s but yeah
I mean Guns and Roses were the biggest
[__] on the planet for you know four
years so Metallica is metal so you need
the over abuse of guitars to be metal no
I mean Metallica's like 8 minute songs
with two minute guitar solos in it you
know like if you listen to Master of
Puppets so it's over abusive and what's
crazy is even like metal people think
Metallica like sellout metal cuz they
sold out with the Black Album their
biggest album cuz they had a ballot on
there oh yeah but that ballot is tight
too you listen to like for for who the
Bell TOS or like one [__] like that like
just big heavy it's funny cuz we have
the same conversations per genre and
that's what I've been trying to say to
you no I mean I think it's all rock and
roll but I think there's metal which is
like rap though there's all rap but
everything in
hip-hop I am everything is Rap a lot of
[__] is rap but everything ain't Hip-Hop
Hip-Hop is like
metal see rock and roll is just rap
anybody could rap anybody can put out a
rap album but hip hop is a special
representation of culture where you you
bear the burden of it all and you carry
it on your shoulders and you know you
you you're judge based off of what's
happening right you know I mean that can
determine if you sell another record not
for sure mean and and that's not what
yachty you know shout out to yachi no
dis I don't know his history but I'm
saying he does he's not he's not
responsible for that yachi can do
anything it's not because kids can do
anything because zo Sama is a kid he
can't just do anything if Zo do some
silly [__] it's a it's some trouble if
some of these young hip-hop artists do
some silly [__] their career is going to
take a hit right I think that's
definitely like true when it comes to
like if you're if you're music and your
persona is hip-hop is street but but
hip-hop is only Street there's nothing
else outside of it I don't think that's
true it is you're just saying I think it
evolved can't you agree things evolve
then metal can evolve yeah so metal
could be ballots no no yes which I I'm
telling you with like hardcore metal
heads I'm a hardcore hip-hop [__] okay
hardcore Dam you're not going to sell it
out so you're trying to say cuz to me it
all can evolve no it can't evolve cuz
hip-hop can never be somewhere where
culture doesn't exist so let me ask you
this in general right if hip-hop can't
evolve it's not no culture evolves but
hip hop right is always going to be
Street Urban culture it can't evolve
into the suburbs cuz suburbs will never
have culture they'll never have the they
don't have the
things cocaine plants cocoa plants right
we can grow them here right me and you
could get a warehouse really and we
could grow them yep inside of Warehouse
with all the lights and water system and
all that right legally but how no
illegally but but we would never have
enough cocaine we never have enough
plants dried up leaves I think it's like
10,000 lbs of dried up leaves or some
crazy [__] you need we would never
create enough leaves to make one [__]
kilo because coca plants don't grow wild
everywhere they don't have
the environment the right Sun the right
conditions to grow that's Hip-Hop
Hip-Hop can only grow there there's no
middle class place where culture is
created they don't need lingo you know
why they don't need slang cuz the
[__] school programs are good see I
don't think that's true though because
there is there is culture created
through in middle class where what
fashion where listen they have tradition
which is which is culture no no
tradition can be an aspect of culture is
it safe to say that like um the
automobile industry was in the in the
midwest was a middle class industry up
until it fell sure but having a job
there for poor people was the culture
right no but those were middle class
people no no they they were middle class
people at that time right but I agree
but that's what I'm saying Hip Hop was
birthed after they shut the factories
down after there was no opportunity
after people was deprived of things I
mean it was also birthed in the Bronx so
it's definitely same thing that's
[__] even worse than that might be
just the same as Detroit right um so all
I'm saying to you is middle class people
can enjoy the music but to say that they
they have there's a culture there is
just not and I've been to a lot of
suburbs hey somehow we broke away from
you telling me how you first Le with
Jugos oh Tech 9 okay Tech 9 Tech 99 um
went on tour with Tech 9 uh Tech love me
Travis love me I went on tour with him
three times three years straight which
tours was this cuz I probably was the
first tour with tech it was just me and
Tech and Chris and cut then the next
tour was me 40 uh that's the tour I saw
you on me 40 uh talking about Joe buts
you guys did house oh slaughter house
slaughter house that was at the um and
k. Jrock Kendrick and Jrock that was on
the uh you you guys did House of Blues
in Vegas yep independent grind tour yeah
I was there yep it was it was Kendrick
Jrock MH me 40 that was when Jrock had
put out that album on strange yep 40 yep
um slaughterhouse and Tech yeah that was
a crazy tour that was fantastic when I
think about it like wow yeah and I
that's why I was telling violent Jay and
he went on this tangent about him and
Tech 9 almost went to war and I was like
that's not what I was asking I was I was
trying to get to the point of you guys
like revolutionizing the merch game and
then he was like bro you yeah but but
they didn't but I was like you guys
share so many of the same fans that it's
like it would that what doesn't make
sense cuz like if you go to a tech show
you're going to see a guy with a
slaughter house or a Slaughter uh a
Hatcher man tattoo and you're going to
see a guy with a strange music tattoo on
the same you know mean a technician and
a [__] they're like a lot of the a
lot of these people are the same you
know what I mean I always thought they
fan base should be called The Strangers
I see what you did there I like
technicians yeah me too shout out to the
uh strange so yeah you got you got
exposed to that world yeah it was
amazing it was amazing to see dog it
[__] my life up you know what I mean
and I think it helped even Kendrick I
think that was a big influence on what
Kendrick did yeah cuz that was this was
2011 10 9 11 yep I think that tour was
11 but I think I I remember he used to
watch him on stage like every night yeah
cuz you got to see you got to know Tech
like Peak Tech with him uh cut coun and
Chris Calico together Tech is probably
the best hip-hop perform it's probably
Tech 9 Buster Buster is up there R and
meth is up there somebody else up there
that I'm not thinking about that's super
dope up on stage but them guys is really
special up there Tech 9 is the goat to
me Tech is hard to [__] with I think cuz
you don't have to know one of tech songs
and that to me is the the key yeah is
that I became a fan of Tech 9 not
knowing any of his songs besides like
slacker and I'm a player I'm a player
true and when I saw him live like list
these song it's funny cuz you listen
songs you be like to me is that's
different I'm not mad and to me Tex
doing two hours
straight no track behind him rapping a
million miles a minute and dancing
dancing
choreography and I'm talking like Peak
Tech tour Tech is a monster and even
like recently I I said this to him he
did a tour you ever had him on the show
many times not on my podcast yet but I
mean I've interviewed Tech PR 10 times
um he had a tour in
2016 or 17 16 maybe SE early 17 and it
was this was when Chris Calico and him
or Chris left strange there's no C coun
so it was just him and to me a part of
like Tech's live show that was super
dope was him and Chris's energy back and
forth yeah but I saw him by himself St
was good St was and he had he had like a
it was like the gangster the the clown
and the king and he somehow bro it was
the craziest Tech show I've ever been to
and it was just him and the way he like
changed his outfit te is that work by
itself bro that [__] is no he's a
professional like when he does this [__]
he does this [__] strange business model
is carried on Show Business well strange
business model is one that more hip-hop
um labels
should adopt well it's hard because you
need a tech
nine and it's hard because it's strict
well the strict part can work but the
tech 9 part is the hard part cuz like
when you were on tour with them you guys
had rules right if you if you didn't
there's no rules it's just your ass
going to miss the bus oh no there's
rules I mean I was no rules to me then
what was the rules there's uh that well
they now they have rules like if you
agree to go on the tour you have to
abide by the rules or they F you yeah I
didn't have that but that was based on
but what's the rules uh no nobody on the
bus that isn't like no girls on the bus
no uh yeah that was nothing like that no
smoking on the bus but that was because
something had happened to cause there's
an incident or an issue that happened
that made those rules each one of those
rules get like so now when you go on
tour with tech you got to sign off on
hey I'm G follow these rules like Dizzy
Wright was so frustrated CU he couldn't
smoke on the bus so he would just pay
the fine [__] yeah N I didn't have they
didn't have something Happ so yeah
something definitely happened yeah but
they they before the rules it was it
might have been the Machine Gun Kelly
tour that caused them to uh put those
rules in before the rules it was just I
don't smoke anyway so it work for me but
before the rules it was just it is very
strict but not strict in rules time like
you really do like oh yeah you're the
will shows in 64 days yeah the bus will
leave you you don't have a choice has no
choice The Show Must Go On yeah you just
fly to the next town did you ever miss
the bus never in life I wouldn't the
rules wouldn't matter to me I don't
smoke a drink I mean I don't even even
care about bringing girls on the
bus I wonder what that tour is like if
OG mugs has to be security for E40 and
Tech 9 that was kind of cool I remember
that people don't know keep running back
out on the stage OG mugs is kind of like
he's tech security guard keep running
back also kind of E40 security guard he
had to keep running back on the stage
and run back it was funny shout out to M
he had to double up yeah that's probably
the roughest tour his his uh he was
complaining he was complaining he was
complaining anyway so the new album is
out cancel these
yeah it's really good man they telling
me it's classic now y'all didn't [__]
it up for me cuz I felt special at first
I've been hearing Scarface sent me fire
emojis about it and [__] been hitting
me talk about how good it is and people
like it's classic then I tweet nobody
with four class and I realize they
classify every album as a class I'm like
y'all just [__] it up for me I thought
I had something special not every album
just four of kany well more than four of
Kanye a dude told me Kanye had eight
Classics okay Kanye's first first five
albums are a classic sure see it just
ruined
it time changing he dropped five dog
first six albums are Classics he dropped
six Doggy Styles in a row he dropped six
IL matics in a row [__] yeah I think
Kanye's first six albums six IL matics
he dropped he
dropped he dropped [__] you really
feel yes College colge Dropout late
registration graduation My Beautiful
Dark Twisted Fantasy 808 well 808
heartbreaks was before my beautiful
darkart Twisted Fantasy um yeus those
are six
Classics I think yeesus is a perfect
album he dropped six IL matics in a row
and um
and outside of
that those are the those are the six I
have to give it to now I I also happen
to feel that if you were to put the uh
Good Friday songs together on a zip file
in the blog era that's a whole other
classic
album I also happen to feel that uh and
just the standards has been lowered dog
kids see
ghost is one of Kanye's greatest bodies
of work ever with him and kid C might as
well say it's a
classic he just make anything a classic
you said it not me he dropped six ill
mics in a row [__] Kanye that's crazy
six ill matics yeah he no he dropped six
well I mean he definitely yeah he's I
mean six in a row yeah six that's why
he's got the greatest hip-hop
discography of all time six ill mxs in a
row I mean he [__] he had he had that
the first three records I mean Outcast
did four straight yeah you know four ill
matics in a row Southern playlist of
Cadillac music alens hey four uh four
get rich drron in a row that's just how
crazy than on wait wait wait yeah
Outcast has five Classics he D five
Classics in a row five get rich of drron
in a row yeah Outcast got five of them
that's just crazy I I can't argue cuz at
this point it's like I ain't never heard
I didn't even know hip-hop had DMX has
one I somebody told me he DMX had four
that's crazy it's not C all this [__] is
crazy y'all it's y'all would make it
like if I listen to Y DMX has DMX has
one this dude told me and a half he told
me Best of Both Worlds is classic he
told me is classic someone told you best
of both world classic you should have
blocked them I'm not I don't block
nobody what I never block people HOV has
got two undeniable Classics and then the
Black Album which is Up For Debate like
this dude said all of these classic he
show me all the album all the Kanye
album he like all these people got
Classics no I'll say this Jay-Z's got
two
undenial which to me is a classic I
think Drake has he said if we talking
about songs H got a 100 classic songs
even Chief keth got them you just
chatting okay I don't know about yeah
this is your people was a white man he
tell and then another dude said I'm so
tired of interaction forming this is the
most obvious bet I've seen all day and
retards on Twitter eat it up no one in
hip-hop has four Classics your Tweet was
no one in hip-hop has four Classics this
is the Tweet so that's the one everyone
look how many [__] views it has yeah
so someone said Outcast which is true
damn 2.9 Million DMX that person should
be
blocked it's going to get worse this is
your people that's just the madness
Jay-Z kany Jay-Z don't have four classes
kany
does uh Cube might be close I might uh
cuish Jay-Z don't uh Outcast de la The
Roots this is your people y'all just say
Nas don't have four the people said n
man I seen Nas probably top five guys
mentioned again n my favorite MC ever he
don't got four but this is the point
y'all don't understand what a classic
album is y'all just saying if it's a
really good album or you think it's
almost perfect or it that's not there's
no way Kanye dropped five G Richard di
trones in a row it's just not true no
you're he did six he didn't drop six in
a row six in a row yeah you were right
no way five CU it was six he didn't drop
Six it was six yeah so six of Kanye's
album is get rich of Dr the first
six the first six yeah this is crazy
yeah I mean I put get rich or die trying
it's funny cuz people think I'm
interacting former like I thought this
was a reasonable point I fig think how
rare it is so people think you were
trolling for the for the interaction I
swear I was like yeah wait a minute am I
tripping like why does this tweet have 3
million views is it safe to say on the
west coast the person that's in the
discussion is
Kendrick I mean I don't know I don't
believe I don't believe I don't believe
no one has four class gobl there's
nobody in the discussion Cube maybe well
I think Cube if you look at America's
most death certificate then you say
Straight Out of Compton and Westside
Connection maybe but then a lot of
people might not look at West Side
connection as a a a a consensus classic
uncultured swine is what we call those
people you feel me but it's like I
wouldn't think I I really thought that I
was like damn there some people that got
close to three like I thought Kanye I'm
like Kanye might have three I thought J
might Kan got six yeah I think Jay might
have three I was like Nas probably has
for sure two life is good is better than
IL Matic but elmatic is a
classic right I disagree I understand
but I'm saying life is good is a better
album no you're wrong then IL mtic but
IL Matic is the classic life is good
isn't even a top for Nas album that's
because Nas fans have bad taste that's
not true uh it was it was written better
no I like life is good no no no no it's
fantastic It Was Written Lost Tapes you
get what I'm saying like if you listen
like I wasn't really the biggest mil fan
but when I listen to that it's cuz
you're [__] 12 and his goat's Litt
Wayne Little Wayne is dope oh
[__] said Lil Wayne got five
Classic Albums oh that's he said all the
Carters I was like hey you should have
blocked whoever said that I was like bro
why but that's as bad as you saying
Kanye got six classes no no listen
there's an argument to be made that
Wayne's got two Carter two and three I
wouldn't even say that and I actually
think my favorite Carter one is the best
one well I was about to say that my
favorite is the Carter one yeah it's the
best one I think Birdman Jr is my
favorite Little Wayne song ever and then
you got I miss my dogs which is we
getting close yeah probably my favorite
Little Wayne song is on the
Carter junor is my favorite but all I'm
saying to you Carter two didn't well you
know what's a classic or close to it
like father like
son see see what I'm saying now and then
Birdman to look at this [__] be like
[__] glass no [__] stunner the
[__] was the [__] but why he got to just
say classic you were signing cash money
right yes but then now I'll say
something B look at me and be like you
just go I'm not sh a classic why why do
we got to go that far it's a cult
classic how about that it's not a not
it's not a hipop it's not a hip-hop cons
the greatest album out of the South is a
Cash Money album It's 400° you [__]
That's a classic by far yes by far 400
degre is the best Cash Money album of
all time it's the greatest album out of
the South and my favorite guy
is 400 degrees is better than is better
but 400 degrees is the best Cash Money
album ever it's the best album out of
the South that's a and I'm not mad at
that take it's not crazy that's a
reasonable take yeah but all my takes
four all your takes are reasonable
what's the worst what's my worst take uh
Kanye don't have four
Classics he's the only one with four
well besides
Outcast Outcast got five Outcast is
batting a th% we won't even count Idol
wild it was a soundtrack cuz AO is a
classic no it was a soundtrack but it's
a classic soundtrack I mean it's not a
bad
soundtrack it's got Hollywood divorce on
there with Little Wayne and it's [__]
up because all these people are like
guys my predecessors I look up to to and
then it makes me sound so crazy cuz I be
like okay like father like son is a cult
classic like the first bigtim album [__]
yeah I got that work no that's not the
first Big Timers out no the first one
that came on universal before the I got
that
work Co classic they just listen they
who they just put that album on the dsps
like two years ago and I was like bro
what the first Big Timers album oh I had
that c three different times
you got so scratched up but that don't
mean you don't look you don't have to
make albums we like a classic you could
just like them bigtim have a I'm going
to start calling certain hip-hop albums
cult classics like all them Kanye are
cult classics Drake Nothing was the Same
cult classic I'm not mad at that I'm not
mad at a cultured class but then what
culture hey 50 Cent The Massacre cold
classic no great album very great album
cold classic no you don't have to put
classic and great together it's just
different it's a cult classic it's not a
cult unit beg for mercy cult classic
that intro is for sure a culture classic
I was just talking about that though
songs like Zoom is a cult classic booie
no
Zoom what the commodor oh I think well
listen bro we're talking about hip hop
I'm thinking boozy zoom zoom we said
culture right so culture CL when I say
cold classic I mean like Kill Bill
volume one and two together it's a cold
classic the big lowski my favorite movie
ever cold classic yeah they create a
culture behind him and people enjoy him
as a group
um here go mystical cold classic here I
go that is a culture classic yeah cuz
now when Deion Sanders wins he says play
me my music yeah and what song is that
it's that wow I didn't know that but yep
so it's it's certain things but you just
got to stop abusing the word classic
like I'm not speaking facts Kanye
doesn't have four Classics you're right
he has six he doesn't have six Kanye
Kanye may have Kanye may have two
Classics kany got the single greatest
discography we've ever seen
followed by Outcast followed
by Ghost Face Killer I'm not mad at the
face I'm not mad at ghost face oh you
know what I got you so Kanye dropped six
purple tapes that's what you said yep
yeah now next time they see you we have
this conversation they see you like
Kanye dropped six purple tape Kanye a
Dro no [__] six purple tapes yeah he
did no he didn't you're right no he [__]
well he dropped uh he dropped do you
know how as ni is you saying he drops do
you know what you saying when you say
that he dropped six purple tapes
yeah this [__] is crazy well go get the
album cancel these nuts go to the cryp
store.com yeah thep store.com grab the
autograph copy you can also go I got
vinyl stream I got cassettes I got
cassette us yeah it's crippy yeah how do
you get vinyl made as an independent
artist these days just pay for it okay I
got is this like distributed to anybody
or you just hand on this yourself n
Olivia's collection I made m
Distribution Company for my
mom's just Distributing it putting it
out there it's all good it's a really
great record they've been telling me
it's classic but y'all [__] it up for
me when I got 3 million people like
viewing the Tweet saying everybody got
four Classics so I'm like damn now I
can't respect y'all [__] opinion I'm
saying my album is a classic I you think
j.cole's got a classic I don't I I
wouldn't listen to enough that's like
asking me if Tim Duncan has a good game
he does I've never really pay attention
he's the fifth best player ever I think
he in the top five too but I just never
watched the games like I can't go back
to a moment ever saw Tim Duncan was like
man Tim Duncan in that moment well he
was cooking the suns in the playoffs my
whole life so I've seen him yeah that
and that's how I feel about jcole like
it let you watch who he playing against
or you watching his career you really he
don't have moments that jump off who's
higher Kobe or
Duncan uh Duncan Duncan as a la [__]
though no [__] all right I just want to
make sure you're a reasonable I'm fair
you are fair yeah top five guys he's top
five he's number five best power forward
ever I don't I say five rings I wouldn't
even I wouldn't even put one through
five I this just the best five players
cuz there five people on the court so it
don't matter who first or fifth they
just all the same that's fair Magic
Michael Jordan LeBron James Tim Duncan
uh Bill
Russell I think it could be Kareem I'm
not AR I'm mad that
or how yall gonna do this year Shaq n
Shaq is not in the top 10 but shout out
to Shaq no no he's top 10 though no you
don't think it's like nine n n I've
always struggled with Shaq between 15
and 25 you don't think with Shaq is
tough as like 11 through 25 sh could be
anywhere because even as a center like
I'm not sure like I wanted some days put
him above up by but he got cooked up by
Hakeem in the finals yep and then do I
put him over Will Chamberlain
yes really yeah four MVPs two
championship 100 point games then ventor
of the big just it just either way I'm
fine yeah I think he's a top five CER I
just don't know if to five potato like
you said it's like three to five he not
Kareem or you're not Bill Russell that's
fair he's not Kareem he's not Bill
Russell and and that's how I start doing
my [__] at position someone who I hate
that's starting to get Force themselves
into these discussions unfortunately is
a Steph Curry's [__] ass yeah he's for
sure a top 10 now he's getting there
he's there now he's there top 10 he's
the second he's the second best point
guard clearly ever magic Steph Zeke no
magic Steph Oscar yes Zeke no Z is like
six I'm going this gonna sound
Blasphemous and this probably my worst
take I'm going Tony Parker over Zeke oh
[__] out of here y okay that's your
worst take at least you acknowledge it
to be your worst take yeah I'm going
that's probably my worst take is Chris
Paul top five PG ever no is he is he six
seven no really he's 10 though no he's
top 10 no you're crazy yeah top 11
through 15 you're crazy I'm going Gary
Payton over him I'm going Dennis Johnson
from Compton over him you're [__]
crazy I'm going uh Jason kid over him
look [__] crazy I'm going uh John
Stockton over him that's a fair that's
fair you w you wouldn't put Nash over
Paul yeah I'm putting Nash over Paul
two-time MVP yeah yeah yeah and he just
was nasty so is Paul Paul is fantastic
but you got to do something with it you
got to go you got to you got to get
there he went no he never went he went
to the finals and played the Bucks did
he play yes I could have swore he was H
well I guess that's not bad yeah I got
to look at that he played the whole
series yeah I still ain't gonna put him
he probably
11 son Suns winning the finals
yeah I I I don't know no defense who
gonna play defense everybody we got
vogle vogo make him
play Fogle one of the most underrated
coaches ever man I'm not mad at that but
he ain't gonna make them play no
defense yeah you got to have some
defense I do like this year because
there's no
clearcut there's a lot of unknown the
disrespect to Denver is just other
worldly well there's a lot bring the
same they lost no they lost Bruce brown
or Bruce Bowen right wait not Bruce
Bowen played for the SP Bruce Brown they
lost Bruce Brown really um they lost
Jeff Green really yeah you get what I'm
saying yeah you're right you're right
you're right [__] like damn that was
luck in Lakers probably had the best off
season no or the
suns suns put together Boston Suns put
together best roster probably Boston
Boston got the unicorn and they got drew
the thing is and they got Drew holiday
so they offense got better I just think
the dope Memphis is a sleeper no they're
not I'm telling you getting Marcus M in
the back court and having uh JJ in the
back JJ's out uh jiren Jackson Jr is
going to be out for 3 to five months he
just got a surgery last week oh my God
and then JN Mor can't play for how many
games yeah but if they hold on they
won't they not without without not
without jiren Jackson They coach well I
don't know I don't know I'm telling you
you got to watch them cuz they got
Scrappy Bunch yeah John rant's the
[__] go is the offensive but he'll
figure it out he'll be all right I don't
know what's wrong I like this season cuz
it's the most it's just a lot of
unknowns except we just disrespected
Denver and I'm not going to disrespect
Denver so Denver is the well I always
say this as I see the the The rosters
currently Denver has the best
player the Lakers have the best
roster all right the podcast is over
this [__] is delusional top to bottom
and the sun's got the and the sun's the
son's got the most this man is
delusional the Lakers the Lakers roster
[__] stat this man is delusional dog
you stop this is what happen it's it's
like when you podcast too long what do
they call that it's like you walk across
the Des you start yeah I never you got
put it on video stop [__] around man
I got to get some help that's some [__]
stop [__] around stop no knows about
your podcast cuz it's Audio Only I have
I do like 20,000 downloads a week you
should be doing 100,000 views a week if
I if I get videos so do it it's not no
you need people to do it like that guy
matters you need one guy his life matter
matters I I need I don't have that one
guy who the [__] is that one guy there's
someone in in [__] pondale waiting
for you to hire them no they I've never
seen him I don't know him you got to go
video I know but you got to have
somebody like that guy back there what's
the name of the podcast so people can go
no Silling people can go [__] listen
to it cuz they can't watch it yes it's a
real podcast it's not a YouTube show
don't don't let charag get don't let
Charlemagne's narrative about YouTube
not mattering get in your head say
YouTube don't matter but a podcast is
what you hear yeah well listen get on
YouTube G Malone I got you I got to find
me somebody you've been telling me this
for this is your second guy like this
third see you just find these [__]
that just cuz you in Hollywood all these
guys are just around the corner people
from Arizona that you met see that's
even that's like some of the talented
Joker is one of the the talented people
I know is from Arizona oh my God that
guy it's incredible what happened to him
he's still making music his face was yes
he's a jug you know he shot Tupac Must
Die is he a jugal yes yeah well he know
he's not a jug he he wouldn't consider
himself a jug well obviously cuz he is a
jug he is I mean he wouldn't be F
painting his face if W for ICP that's
true but he's like probably the most
talented person I know and he's from
[__] Arizona I don't know why Arizona
is just hot bed for talent but [__] is
not
happening um I think y'all Gatekeepers
are just bad and I think you're a
gatekeeper I'll be trying yeah you got
to really put on for try see this what
I'm saying you got to Bear the burden of
Phoenix Arizona and the cultures of all
the the surrounding cities that's your
responsibility you got to put on I try
they all come up here they all rap I
give them interviews I do my best to
push their music I do my I do my best I
helped I helped my boy mkam get on sway
there we go uh I try you got to do more
this is the point of being a hip-hop
person you got to carry the burden of
Arizona culture there are some dope a
rappers no it's dope a everything do a
got some real talent
going to be your next home you're going
to end up moving there yeah I own the
dope Club there 1111 I know because you
have [__] you're smart [__] a go
up yeah all right well listen man
everyone go support the new album please
uh cancel these nuts we had a million I
think we had a million streams on
Spotify already so I know people talking
good about it go run it up and purchase
a purchase a physical copy cryp
store.com appreciate you g Malone thank
you so much my brother there it is
what's going on man I want to shout out
to our family a hard Dean for presenting
to you another interview all right
there's another interview coming
tomorrow and in the next day and the
next day shout out to Hardin though if
you're in Las Vegas man the number one
dispensary in the world there are family
there are brothers there are [__]
dogs over there man we love them they
always are taking care of us and they'll
take care of you if you go to harden in
Vegas let's say you're Landing in Vegas
you're going to go watch the Raiders
you're going to go watch a Vegas show
whatever get in that taxi tell them
straight up take me to harden when you
get to harden they going get you hooked
up with the craziest uh just variety and
selection of Premium cannabis on the
planet and if you tell them you heard
about us on the on on the bootleg C show
you say hey Harden I heard about y'all
on the bootleg cev podcast they're going
to take care of y'all all right so go
follow him Hardin Las Vegas on all
social media and check them out Hardin
vegas.com what's up Harden